leurs actions ont marqué l'imaginaire
des années 2010
en ukraine où le mouvement est né et
ailleurs dans le monde où il s'est
étendu
mise en scène des femmes seins nus qui
rugissent leur colère les prises de
position des feymen résonne encore
aujourd'hui
à l'origine elles sont fort prix l
exploitation du corps de la femme ça
m'avait donné comme un coup de tonnerre
en plein visage
parce que je m'attendais pas que les
femmes de mon pays d'origine se rebelle
contre un système patriarcal zinnias
czerny chauvin quitter l'ukraine pour le
québec à l'âge de 12 ans le passage à
kiev en 2012 elle est invitée par les
femen à participer à une action pour
appuyer du coup si riot
un autre doctrine east alors condamné à
la prison en justice j'avais pas
réalisé l'envergure et de l'impact que
ça allait produire dans le monde entier
parce que l'action consistait quand même
à tronçonner une croix
elle a dû fuir le pays
parce qu'évidemment c'est elle qu'on
voyait le plus à ce que maintenant les
femmes se sont émancipés je crois que
oui quand même et je crois que le
mouvement il ya joué un rôle est ce
qu'un lien à faire avec la gagne en ce
moment moi je le vois je vois dans le
symbolisme maintenant je vois que la
femme ukrainienne elle est beaucoup plus
présente elle est combative elle et elle
n'a pas peur d'autres font la même
lecture de la situation notamment sept
professeurs qui s'intéresse au rôle des
femmes dans les conflits armés elles ont
une voix on les entend moi je vois on
les entend souvent à la radio on à leurs
témoignages y en a certains qui sont
partis du parlement il ya beaucoup de
femmes dans l'armée
proportionnellement à d'autres pays rome
6 coeurs il y a aussi des aspects de la
guerre qui vise spécifiquement les
femmes comme le viol comme arme de
guerre donc particulière on voit ça dans
tous les conflits maintenant
elle c'est derrière la cousine de xenia
elle vient de s'installer chez elle à
montréal après avoir fui son pays en
guerre
contrairement à xénia ne jamais adhéré
au mouvement femen au contraire elle
était opposée à leur démarche mais le
courage des fans de son pays
actuellement l'hymne d'air
il travaille pour se protéger protéger
aussi leurs familles et leurs enfants de
la violence et elles manifestent pour
dénoncer la violence et les viols qui se
sont produits un mario quoi les buttes
chat
aujourd'hui le mouvement femen existe
toujours
au québec les activités sont sur pause
mais le chapitre existe toujours après
avoir fait les manchettes à de
nombreuses reprises dans les années 2010
le mouvement a toutefois connu plusieurs
crises notamment les figures de proue du
mouvement de santons des postes sur la
direction à donner on fait même une mort
tragique a aussi eu l'effet d'un coup de
sonde oksana jusqu'au aussi suicidé ce
lundi à paris c'est une forme artistique
de protester de se prononcer xénia
depuis quitté les rangs des feymen
personnellement je vois phénomène comme
un échec en soi
parce qu'il n'a pas réussi le mouvement
n'a pas réussi à sauver l'âme des femmes
qu'ils étaient là à l'intérieur le
suicide qui a quand même
été plus d'une qui a emporté oksana tout
ça ça me rend triste ça m'a énormément
triste et je pense qu'en trop de même
dans ma propre famille avec mes proches
c'est c'est tabou
j ai honte d'en parler maintenant
pourquoi parce que selon ma famille ça a
rien apporté de bon le regard de xenia
il de sa cousine sont maintenant tournés
vers l'ukraine des six veaux ends
j'essaie de croire que ça prendra fin
bientôt et que nous pourrons retourner
chez nous mais des fois c'est difficile
de croire que tout ira mieux
[Musique]
dario ne sait pas encore quand ici elle
pourra retourner chez elle à kiev en
attendant elle se posera chez sa cousine
à montréal et tentera elle aussi d'aider
à sa façon ses compatriotes